hello everyone welcome back to the
collider interview Studio at Fantastic
Fest 2023 I am sitting here with the
filmmakers behind there's something in
the barn I told you this before we
started rolling I love the fact that
this is Gateway horror for everybody to
enjoy congratulations on your movie
thank you thank you thank you so a lot
of our viewers are first going to be
learning about your movie right now
through the Festival whoever would like
to do this can some I'm going to give a
brief synopsis of your movie that's you
that's me yes always
you it's the story about an American
Family who inherited a farm in Norway
they're Norwegian Americans by ancestry
but they probably never been there and
they go to this Farm uh and on this Farm
There lives a creature that really
doesn't
appreciate anything to be honest but at
least not new influences and new people
so the movie is based on actual Barn elf
mythology can one of you run us through
that mythology but then also tell us
what things you've added to it to make
it cinematic or more cinematic maybe
yeah I mean the mythology goes way back
a long time U but it's never really been
done anything you know to sort of this
very very specific folklore in in nor
way other than uh songs and post cards
and things like that uh so this is the
first time obviously that there is a
movie about it we did add I mean there
that we all know from childhood that the
barn elves are pretty grumpy and kind of
scary um but they're also very helpful
uh and they like a balance in their life
so a balance where humans and elves in
the barn can live side by side and they
kind of help each other if you know if
the barn get some food and and stuff
like that then you know the barn elf
will help so we added a couple of uh
rules that they do not like like too
much
noise um nothing that is very very
modern you know is a very traditionalist
um it doesn't like loud noises and
changes and you know things like that
and here comes the Americans that is
everything like that yeah this makes all
the sense in the world um is there any
other Norwegian mythology and folklore
that you would think would make a really
good horror movie that's also you
question well there's there's plenty
there's plenty really really really uh
we already had some right now we had
troll right which is with the Norwegian
trolls the original trolls and you had
tall some years ago about the HRA the
female uh temptress which is very much
like the
sirens uh but there's one called nuckin
which is a really really creepy one who
lives what is that about he lives in in
The Lakes forest in the lakes and the
rivers and uh super SC
lures you out and pulls you under I feel
like that kind of Mythology is so much
richer everywhere else in the world than
it is in the States but I want to take
this idea and kind of flip it around for
both of you let's say we were making a
movie and like you are at uh you were in
a family that's moving to the states and
there's some sort of like mythical
creature here that you would piss off to
the point that it would attack you what
creature would that
be I don't know some W Street guy maybe
yeah that's the right answer like Trump
Pro Trump guy yeah we were talking about
this before and I was like the only
thing that I could choose is probably
like like a werewolf because I love
animals so I would go to pet it and then
it would just bite me and then I would
be now go to be the vitim that to begin
with you
know um so I love holiday horror movies
also I'm very happy that you guys gave
us another uh Christmas movie to love
right now if you had the the opportunity
to turn another holiday into a horror
movie what holiday would you choose and
why I would choose Easter um because we
also have this tradition in Scandinavia
um to do um really dark crime uh TV
shows during Easter and sort of like you
know six seven episodes something like
that Nordic Noir it's very very really
belongs to to Easter um also Easter is a
time where you read you know really dark
and violent crime books uh so it would
actually be amazing to do something that
is very you know belongs to Easter
because that's also the time we do spend
time U with family and uh we're all
gathered in cabins in the mountains and
uh it's a good opportunity to do
something that uh is a new kind of a
holiday okay I'm always into that same
for you Easter or something else for
Easter also maybe mix up with the Bible
History with all the the crazy people
really buying into that uh sorry uh so
uh it's it's it's it's a good mix and
and a bunny of course okay yeah of
course you need you need a horrific
bunny as well all right so for your
movie in terms of it being a Christmas
horror movie is there any other
Christmas horror movie you've seen that
you think did it well and you kind of
wanted to embrace and emulate it but
also I want to know something you've
never seen in a Christmas horror movie
before that you wanted to make sure was
in your own that was a lot of
questions big questions Tarter Tarter
opposites there I mean we didn't
necessarily looked I mean obvious yes we
did look at some Christmas movies but
not horror movies we were really looking
at Gremlins and things like that it's
horror movie absolutely but not not
necessarily A
Christmas uh as such um so but it was
really about looking back to you know
the the movies that we grow up with and
that felt a little too scary when we
were 12 years old and also that had a
lot of fun comedy in it um so it was
basically that what's an example of a
movie like that for you that you grew up
with as always you know grow you started
watching things that were way too
violent and way too scary um that is
just sort of I think that's the way in
but you can't really make that if your
intention is to is to make something for
you know I'm I'm I'm thinking very much
that I'm making this for my own son
who's 13 uh but I also know that he does
watch things that I am thinking you
shouldn't watch this but also I don't
care because I watch the same things I
was going to say I'd be the worst person
to give anyone advice on what's okay for
their children just because I grew up
watching like the most inappropriate
things in the world you're good it's
fine it's fine I feel like like I'm a
sound ins saying horror lover right now
so nothing bad Happ the only thing I ask
afterwards or before he starts watching
you know something that is way too scary
is maybe don't go around afterwards and
do what they are doing in this movie
don't kill
people I'm not stupid honestly I would
see a movie like this go to a barn where
there could be a barn out and I would
try to summon it and make it do these
crazy things so I want to talk a little
bit about the casting of your family
here so after that two-part question
I've got a four question now for you I
want to know something unique about each
of them as an actor where it demands
something different from you as an
actor's director uh I mean we can start
with Martin star who is insanely funny I
think uh but also he's funny in a way
where I'm not really sure at all times
if he's joking or if he serious so that
was kind of
annoying that is like his his comedy
style so so you sort of have to sort of
move around that fact and always kind of
is he joking now or is he serious I
don't know I just have to sort of take
for granted that it's actually serious
and then I approach it as a serious
thing and then normally turns out he was
actually joking regard regardless so
that took a little bit of handling
um am who plays the mom or the new mom
stepmom new mom um I never thought she
was as funny uh as she is I was she's a
great actress uh but she's incredibly
funny and incredibly rude which is
perfect from my sense of
humor and then you had a two kids um
so uh so uh is American
Norwegian it doesn't have that much
experience but um I found her to be
incredibly professional and really good
sort of i' been thinking afterwards that
you know she's a she could do a good
career of being a screen screen Queen
she's really good at that I think second
that yeah yeah yeah and then you had
towns who has done just not
movies at all you know it's just yeah he
he's done some school plays but he just
a kid
um and I think with kids who doesn't you
know haven't had the experience of you
know being on a movie set with our very
strict rules and you know we do
this uh
he it was kind of making him understand
that this is actually a job you can't
mess around and you know just have fun
uh all the time you you actually have to
focus it's fair enough you do a lot of
fun stuff in this movie though to build
on that with the two of them what is
something you appreciated about
collaborating with them that you're
excited for more directors to get to
experience when they make movies with
them in the future I always like to
think that film making generally is a
something that you do together uh not
only with the actors but uh with the
whole crew uh it's a very collaborative
process and I always encourage that so
it's it's that nothing else yes I like
that approach all right talking about
your your barn elf now can you maybe
pinpoint the biggest difference between
how you pictured the barn elf looking
like day one first design you ever came
up with and now what we see in the
finished product do you want to say
something now talking a lot we we he's
exactly what we wanted to have he really
is and that's very much due to the actor
we we cast in the role Kiran sha who's
been doing every big movie since Indiana
Jones and Temple of Doom he was he was
Elijah Woods standing for all the scenes
where he was not playing himself so when
we got him and fitted him into what we
hoped he could be he was amazingly
perfect right away and he he looks like
if if you if you look at the postcards
of the barnels throughout the centuries
in Norway he's the picture of them he
really is so he's he's fantastic no it
truly is and I think when I look back at
the first concept drawings that we had
of the barn elf it's exactly like that
it's perfect he is something else in
that role all right looking at some of
your big set pieces here going into
production which one did you think would
be the most challenging to pull off and
ultimately was that the toughest or did
a different one Catch You by surprise no
I think maybe obviously everything that
you know involves um you know a lot of
action and stunts and craziness uh like
this that we call the home invasion
where the elves are attacking for the
first time
um it's complex and and and tricky to
shoot and tricky to organize but
everything is is in the planning
obviously so it was just about you know
making sure that we planned everything
as perfectly as we could the other I
guess problem that we had I guess and
that uh
was uh when we moved to Norway to um
shoot all the exterior scenes uh and
being a Christmas movie you want snow
uh and that's also why we want to shoot
in Norway uh but this is global warming
so there were no snow there when yeah
we're supposed to shoot January February
but we were shut down by Co and that
that year it was 2 meters with the snow
was so much snow everything we wanted
but we had to push it eight months and
shoot in the fall instead so we started
in studio and then moved over to
exterior Norway and when we when we land
in Norway to start shooting there in in
late remember yeah uh there was
absolutely no snow and we were starting
to shoot the day after it started to
snow that night so we really got it but
that that's like a challenge you just
get we started to to haul in trucks
truckloads with snow from the mountain
tops uh but that's that's life uh that's
life and that's the nature of film
making oh absolutely absolutely there is
you know it's only problems that's
that's all there is so so the weather
the weather was a challenge you had to
overcome can you give me another example
of like a day on set when nothing was
going to plan you had to find a creative
way to Pivot but a scene turned out
better off because of it I don't think
necessarily you know there was you know
days with trouble because it was so cold
because it can be extremely cold without
snow so uh for the whole time I was you
we were shooting in nowhere it was super
cold so basically you know then you run
into problems where the equipment
doesn't work any longer because it's all
so finely tuned it's all you know
very fine technical cameras and they
just shut down so I can't really say the
N got better yeah that's fair that is a
fair concern you have to take all the
gear inside and you have to you know
make sure that you know they they warm
up a little bit and then okay you're
looking at the okay we'll lose three
hours and you just have to shoot it
regardless um you know it becomes
something if it's better or wor I don't
know uh at the same time they were so uh
sharpened and ready to go because they
were so cold so they wanted to nail the
scenes immediately yeah and there was a
couple of times there where for instance
I was extremely uh worried about uh
Martin and the rest of the uh the family
because they were just hanging out
outside uh I think you should you know
we're setting up C you don't have to be
here go inside and warm up uh but Martin
especially he really wanted to to be
outside because then he got Frost real
Frost in his bed and I just felt that
that looks good my worst nightmare is
not being attacked by Angry Barn eles
it's being in a location like that where
I'm just too cold the entire time I'm a
big baby in the cold I'm the only one in
100 degree Austin weather complaining
about being in air conditioning so we
are in Austin we're here for fantastic F
you both said that you have seen some
other movies here and one of my favorite
things about this Festival is that it's
the genre loving Community all together
and it's everyone being supportive of
each other 's work so can you each
pinpoint something you saw another
filmmaker do in their movie that made
you think like damn that's impressive
and I'm inspired by it I mean we just
came out of uh Kim's video uh which was
a really really fun movie a documentary
and super fun and I think the most
inspiring thing there is that they
actually did everything that they did in
that film and they went back to uh Italy
to retrieve a big collection of uh films
and they staged a Big Heist so that did
a lot of things that I was thinking I
would never do this
just my see yeah I I saw River uh which
is that's another one of D fantastic in
the sense that it has a concept and it
just follows through and it has this
two-minute Loop going on and on and on
and you're thinking they can't pull it
up but they really really do and it's so
inspiring just to see them doing it and
thinking well it's ways of thinking
differently and doing things differently
so it's really really cool it's the best
thing about a festival like this your
movie and you two are in very good
company here huge congratulations on
there's something in the barn thank you
you Merry out there if you like holiday
horror do not miss it check it out and
stay tuned for more from Fantastic Fest
2023 very
soon